Lisa wrote in what are your excuses for
leaving really lame events my go-to is
that I have to get up really early the
next day and I know that that's so lame
and there's a funny Seinfeld about when
Elaine has some boyfriend who said he
had to go home he had to get up early
the next day so he had to leave yeah
instead of going up to her place or
something like that
Jerry jokingly says other than like a
farmer nobody has to get up so early the
next day that you wouldn't go upstairs
if a woman invites you upstairs which
it's sort of a joke but I use that
pretty often I just say I've got to get
up early the next day or whatever
although there are better ones that
people could use like if you have a kid
that's the best thing which is we got to
get home you know Pat jr. has gotten to
you of whatever you know something
something's going on with that jr. we
got to get home to feed the dog that's
one that it's lame but it actually does
work and it's completely realistic I
don't know those are some of the common
ones I think of or you can just leave it
a bit more ambiguous like oh I have a
medical thing to attend to I have a
doctor's appointment well I've got to go
home to the emergency I have to go take
my insulin right I mean that would be
one that I see now I think it's bad
karma even though I don't believe in
karma to any time use medical excuses
that don't actually apply to you because
I feel like even though I don't believe
in karma it's and I don't even really
believe in luck I believe in odds I
still just think it's not good to say to
use illness like I never pretended to be
sick to call out of work because I
thought it's just bad because then when
I'm really sick then it's not going to
be believed or whatever the case may be
so I generally shy away from that but if
you really do have some kind of medical
reason those are very good reasons to
leave some kind of event you know if
you're in a big audience where it's not
going to really be noticed if you leave
entirely and don't come back I don't
even think you have to give an excuse
you can just kind of head out the door
and people will assume you're going to
the bathroom or something that's called
the Irish goodbye and I have no idea if
that's an offensive term I genuinely
have no idea but and I don't know where
it came from and I really hope it
doesn't have to do with like drinking or
that it's offensive in some way but a
lot of my friends talk about how they
always do the Irish goodbye which is
when they're out at a party they don't
say bye to anybody they just
disappear and then people will just
assume oh I must have just missed when
they were saying bye sure and talk to
them the next day or whatever the case
might be yeah even if it's not like a
boring event where you're listening to
someone speak you know you just head out
the door I don't want to listen to that
stuff I prefer to you have good ways
like for me the issue is line ow say no
to lots of events so I'm less commonly
at events I don't want to be at but I'm
often in conversations I don't want to
be in with specific people so you can't
really do this at like a wedding for
example because it would just come off
as rude but at any kind of business
event I found and someone taught this to
me the great Tom wall of Western
Massachusetts fame taught me this one
which is if you want to cut off a
conversation at anything
business-related at any point you just
ask for a card this will create a
situation where the person you're
talking to has to get the card and it's
not rude because you're so interested in
this person that you're asking for a
card presumably to contact them again at
some point in the future and then as
soon as they hand you the card you
immediately put out your hand you say
thanks so much really nice talking to
you Lucas and you've created a situation
where okay we've exchanged cards and
shaking hands clearly the conversation
has now ended and I also do it there's
nothing else to do at that point that's
a really good one that that generally
seems to work for me I like that one
yeah try that one Pat if you need to at
some point